[Music]
i hear the sound of victory
i hear the sound of victory
[Music]
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to the i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just warn
you
this may not be suitable for children
for children
hey little prickles now that your uh
your
hero is there are you going to sit there
in your little kimono and wear your
little hat
rice because it's going to be called
no free speech red chinese communist
speech but you can't have pork because
you might offend the ayatollahs
after all you're going to love this too
you're going to make a bomb and i hope
they drop it right on your freaking ass
but you can't have pork but you can't
have pork
but you can't have pork just kick that
microphone right up your ass
[Music]
[Music]
you can't
[Music]
this is highly triggered this is an
extremely triggered
[Music]
you can't have pork you can't have pork
you can't have pork
[Music]
falls yesterday we had three big ones
really big
suppression balls don't give me the
umbrella i'm soaking wet already
they put numbers you know they're called
suppression suppression balls
they make you like feel badly so you
said your wife you said your husband
darling let's go out to dinner and then
we'll come back we love our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
in almost everywhere the real
[Music]
suppression balls
there i am wow i just did about five
minutes of stream
and didn't even realize i wasn't on
camera that was bizarre
uh wow
i should even just cancel the stream
that was so humiliating
should i just end it like just take it
fresh tomorrow that was pathetic
holy [ __ ] um okay
i'm self-canceling yeah that's exactly
right it's like self-cucklery
um what are we even watching here so
joe biden today met with the family of
george floyd on the one year anniversary
of the shooting of george i'm sorry of
the death of george floyd not the
shooting of george floyd
and um you know we've heard much from
republicans and democrats about getting
police reform through
and it's completely stalled and it's
pathetic so we're going to have some of
that stuff
um upcoming we're also going to look at
some right wing media i have some
memes i have some unban requests i have
voicemails we're going to review an old
interview of mine with brian fisher by
popular demand this is one that maybe a
lot of people
um in the audience are not familiar with
and we have clips and we have images and
we we have just
all sorts of hey is that dr oz that is
bizarre that is like a low rent dr oz
or maybe dr oz is a low rent that guy
that's bizarre
um but yeah so we have a lot of
different things to to do and to talk
about but man i am shaken up by
streaming for like three minutes and i
wasn't even on screen that was crazy
pepe xanadu asks via super chat
how did your parents decide to migrate
to the usa from all the other countries
available to them my dad was offered a
job in the usa from the full list of
countries
the only country where he had a job
offer
was the united states so it was a uh it
was a slate of one
jacob says what are the consequences of
the january 6 committee failing in the
senate what should be done if it fails
uh i don't know i think democrats just
need to figure out a way to push it
through regardless
and if you can do it there may be
another structure to such a commission
that it wouldn't be the same but where
you wouldn't need senate approval
let's cross that bridge when we come to
it i believe i heard today that mitt
romney willard mitt romney
is going to be voting in favor of it um
so that is uh that is a good thing let
me say
a big thank you to kenil shah
who just signed up at joinpackman.com
and is new member number one
also big thank you to gilgo m for the
twitch sub
4 months kiss my toe beans
for the twitch sub flea girl artistic
simplicity
18 months if you can imagine that really
appreciate the four of you
and we have two things on target today
if we get to a hundred not only will
phone lines open
i will film an updated backyard garden
video
what i showed you 10 days ago is nothing
compared to what i have now
i have probably two dozen strawberries
my green peas are climbing to the moon
i am holding green peas so two things on
uh
on target today uh if we do get to 100.
now where to start first
let me start with a couple of voicemails
okay
these are new i don't even remember what
these are these have been flagged
the first one is called david super
pac-man show
that sounds interesting let's take a
listen to it
here we go hey david alvin from sweden
here
so i wonder with the david pakman show
growing and growing
how will uh it continue to
further progressive causes right for
example will it
we'll keep doing the david pakman show
uh
as it is on schedule now or will it
expand will it be uh
david pakman pack pack super pac or
something
uh i know you you're against money in
politics and
that whole system but yeah uh yeah
that's what i was wondering i'm sorry
excuse my english it's not my native
language
thanks bye all right very good so
important questions coming in from
sweden will it become the super pac show
or something like that
this voicemail is just labeled jewish
condoms so i'm a little scared on this
one but let's
let's listen i guess you ever think
maybe if jewish people wore condoms the
thought of them having money and
controlling the media
might be a little less disgusting of a
thought
wait a second what i think this was a
response to my segment on anti-semitism
i don't even think i understand that
what does that even mean
i'm going to have to listen to that is
bizarre
let me see if i can figure that out hold
on
why isn't it playing you ever think
maybe if jewish people wore condoms
the thought of them having money and
controlling the media might be a little
less disgusting of a thought
yeah i i'm pretty sure it's anti-semitic
but i don't really unders that is a
bizarre voicemail
what on earth does that mean does
anybody know
is she saying jewish people should not
reproduce that is
disgusting and weird it doesn't make
sense okay and then
last one is i guess some kind of tech
trouble i love tech trouble voicemails
let's see
hi um today friday the 21st of may i
made a comment on david's item on the 35
repub
republicans voting for the january 6th
riots commission
and i received a reply from the quote
david pakman's show with a picture of
david
but according to my youtube notification
the message actually came from
capital.com
and had a numerical reply which i don't
understand
these so this is so this woman sounds
absolutely lovely and delightful and i
love her support
the frequency with which we get
technical support
voicemails and messages
so like and they just it's just we have
no idea what's going on like we get all
of these different messages whereas
people will say
hey um i went to your website
and was redirected to
you know uh newsmax and then they stole
my credit card
and they and it's like listen you might
have some spyware but this has nothing
to do with our website or i'll get
messages from people who say
david facebook has blocked you
i used to get you on my facebook and we
don't get you anymore
and it's like listen we ca i'm sorry i
don't know everything's fine on facebook
um we have an internal term where all
like if i get something that i think is
a bonafide issue
i'll send it to pat and i'll be like is
this user error meaning like it doesn't
there's nothing for us to fix it's just
you know it's a tech thing um this like
this woman may have some kind of
redirect or some
something might be wrong with her
computer let's see so i was wondering
why did i receive this message from
capital.com no idea and i don't
understand what
what the message uh says so i sent them
an email asking about this and i haven't
received a response yet
so i just want to know if this is fishy
or it's just
okay so i'm marion
oh okay well she goes in to give her her
phone number then so we're going to stop
that
yeah it's it bums me out because we
can't pot so we probably get 50
technical support requests a day of
different kinds
five are relevant to platforms we
control like five of the 50
actually relate to our website other
things are like
maybe something's glitchy with youtube
maybe something's glitchy with facebook
and then the vast majority are
unfortunately what we refer to as user
error and we just can't keep up with it
we we
it's we quite literally cannot keep up
with it
so that's that some nice voicemails a
few other super chats coming in pepe
xanadu says enough garden
update the drum solo video okay
david what are your thoughts on the late
argentine philosopher mario bunche
reading his social science under
debate any other recommendations no uh i
have i have not read
uh his work unfortunately and would not
be able to comment
and dominic says do you think you might
be a super spreader mr president yeah
that was quite an event
we should commemorate the one-year
anniversary of that okay
let's get to a few other things do
people want
unban requests next or do you want
the new remix from
the steven kenneth destiny bonnell the
second
subreddit unban requests or the stephen
kenneth destiny bonnell
i'll do both
we'll do the unban requests first okay
yeah let's do that i actually have
a lot of unban requests here uh we are
calling to order
this court of unban requests uh i have
my gavel
there is a mechanism an element on
twitch where if you were to get banned
you could appeal the ban
and if and when you do that i get a
message and we can look at it okay
here is a user named labonte tech
official which i recognize right away
this is someone we've banned
under about seven or eight different
names and they keep
making new accounts they created a new
account on the day of the last stream
on that very same day they showed up and
they said the following
david pakman d pacman they posted a
bunch of numbers
they posted another bunch of numbers
they posted another bunch of numbers
they posted another bunch of numbers
they then posted their personal phone
number
they were timed out they then posted
their personal phone number again and
asked me to call them
then they then attempted to post a
direct link to a members only piece of
content
then they said f david pakman and they
were banned
their unban request is my phone number
is
and then go here to get the bonus show
it is not a bot
this we know who this person is that is
a deny
and permaban all right that is that
next unban request is from a user named
diabolus musica
they've been in the chat for a while
they're the the oh my god
their last thing that they did was
during the last
stream they showed up
and were just sending relentless
messages in
all caps and they were the messages
themselves were not
particularly offensive but they were
asked multiple times to turn off
all caps then they started sending all
caps messages like don't show your
garden again you trash human
being who eats this trash
i want to hear how trump won the
election again this is all caps
trump is about to win are we tired of
winning yet
all in caps repeatedly asked to stop
using caps lock
then they said my keyboard has
the china virus and only has capital
letters
at that point they were panned their
unban request
is why was i banned
my keyboard has the china virus come on
that's a perma-ban okay
next user this is a user named matt
welch matt welch came in
and said jews are pulling the strings
they were immediately banned and then
their unban request was
it's a little bit anti-semitic but it
was fair to bring up
okay that's a perma-ban come on guys
and then here is another user
who oh they were just banned they just
showed up and they said
about the remembrance of the george
floyd
um death imagine praising
a drug addict they were banned and their
unban request is nazi
mods so that is a perma
all right so that's a lot of uh that's
that's
not not good not good
um all right so that is everything as
far as
unban requests are concerned thank you
very much
i do want to say uh thank you to ryan
for the super chat who says great
channel love the content thanks ryan
very much appreciate that
also thank you to seraph of lies for six
months subscribed on twitch
dragonfly back home 21
months subscribed and sends the message
i've been
subbed 21 months on jeff bezos's dime
love it love it um
that is two putting us at seven
and we will open phone lines if we get
to 100. all right
very good uh next let me see i just want
to make sure i'm not missing anything
okay here is the latest remix from the
steven kenneth destiny bonnell ii
subreddit where someone i guess put
together all the times that i said
stephen kenneth destiny benell ii this
probably took a lot of work check this
out
uh get an alert uh a google alert
that there are clips of mine posted to
the cv
subreddit uh that's pretty good i like
that that probably took a really long
time to make i don't even know how you
would go about finding all those clips
but that's that's pretty trippy
i like that let me look at that one more
time get an alert
uh a google alert that there are clips
of mine
posted to
that's great and if you actually look at
the detail
my hair it's almost like a brady bunch
i'm in different locations my facial
hair is completely different in some of
these
let's even take a look look at that that
is something
my hair here compared to my hair here
it's like a different person
facial hair backgrounds microphones
everything is this is really nicely done
i like it
the user i guess it's someone who goes
by the name dank memes i don't know
uh this this user is under the
impression that i've
that i've been omni-pilled and that is
that's a very aggressive claim which we
would have to adjudicate probably with a
bandhammer
okay um let's continue next
i've got what else do i have oh okay
this is bizarre um radical
reactionary rancid republican
congresswoman lauren beaubert
for some weird reason a few days ago
said
no one died of covet in texas since
march 2nd
where did she get that idea i don't know
let's listen to this
you know i'm really enjoying uh telling
speaker pelosi to kiss my mask
though uh yesterday thomas
hawthorne brian mast beth van dyne
and several other colleagues joined me
in refusing to wear
a mask on the house floor thomas massey
and i both got
warnings and both of our letters ended
up in the same exact place ironically
the trash leftists won't even listen to
the bureaucratic the bureaucrats at the
cdc
and it just goes to show that this
party's follow the science slogan is a
total joke just like this entire
administration just like the entire what
is she talking about by the way
your democrat party um they want to tell
you to listen to science and listen to
data and facts but they haven't done
that for more than a year
uh two weeks to slow the spread turned
into communism
really really quickly now it's your
paper oh my god
yep two weeks to slow the spread next
thing you know
the government owned all the grocery
stores but
don't forget gina texas removed their
mask
mandate two months ago and sleepy joe
called it
neanderthal thinking no sir republicans
are just
following the science and since removing
the mass
two months ago texas has not reported a
single covered death what is she talking
about
texas has not reported a single coveted
death since
the second of march let's take a look at
that
all right so texas
here's cases here's deaths
march 2nd is here
so march 3rd 266 deaths march 5th 277
march 6 222 march 9 168
so thousands of deaths she says zero
deaths
since they ended the mass mandate the
real number is thousands of deaths
do you guys think she doesn't realize
that or does she know she's lying
but she thinks her audience wouldn't
realize it like what's the
what's even the explanation for that i
don't even i don't get it
it's very weird she said they didn't
report a single one they reported way
more than that that's true
there's not been a single day on which
they reported just one death
maybe there's some bizarre backwards
grammar that would make that true
really weird so lauren bobert just out
and out lying
really strange um okay other things i
wanted to go over with you guys
here is a recently uncovered video of
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
now here she is and here i'm going to
explain this one to you
this is marjorie taylor green arguing
last year
that she wouldn't even be okay
removing hitler statues even hitler
statues
she would fight against the removal of
all right let's listen to this one now
for you all um going into a runoff and
voting for me
i also want to say something else i
think
that this is a time where our nation is
being divided
and we shouldn't be we should be brought
together because
this is the greatest country in the
world and we
like the other man was saying about
breadcrumbs i don't think we should be
fighting about breadcrumbs
i think we should be working to come
together and work
further to keep things good
and keep peace we're seeing situations
where christopher
columbus george washington abraham
lincoln
all kinds of statues are being attacked
and it seems to be just
a an effort to take down history
and whether i see a statue that may be
something that i would fully disagree
with like adolf hitler
maybe a statue of satan himself
a statue of satan there's an idea i
would not
want to say take it down but again it's
so that i could tell my children and
teach others
about who these people are what about
reading a book
you know it's like i i'm trying to think
back to when i learned in school about
the civil war and u.s history and world
war
ii you know the teacher makes
presentations and you watch
documentaries and you read things
we need to go do a field trip to a
hitler statue to really understand world
war ii like what on earth is she talking
about and maybe she's from
a maybe her framing is but you know
she's not really familiar with books i
don't know
um maybe she can't even read that's a
good point
but it is a very strange she would even
be opposed to removing
statues of hitler weird
there's just something very very wrong
with this woman very very wrong
okay next let's go to this is like
groundhog's day
today gensake wearing green
yesterday gensake wearing blue it was a
different day
different um a press briefing but peter
ducey from fox news on both days
asking the same question like the movie
groundhog's day
what about investigating whether kovid
was man-made
both days okay here's the first clip
this is from yesterday
new investigation but with 589
920 dead americans at what point does
president biden say
we don't want to wait for the who we
don't know what they're doing this needs
to be
an american-led effort to get to the
bottom of what happened
well first of all we need access to the
underlying data and information
in order to have that investigation and
why not but he talks all the time about
how
he's known president xi for a long time
so why can't he just
and we need them for that information i
think you're misunderstanding how this
process
actually works an international
investigation it's not misunderstanding
he just doesn't understand
led by the world health organization is
something that we've actually been
pressing for
for several months in coordination with
a range of partners around the world
we need that data we need that
information from the chinese government
well we can't
that was weird just kind of froze and
what i would caution anyone doing
is leaping ahead of an actual
international process
we don't have enough data and
information to jump to a conclusion at
this point in time
so is there any amount of the
casualties from coven in this country
that would make you want to
not wait for it what a dumb way of
rephrasing this is it's just it's very
bizarre international
effort and just do it as well i i have
to say
i think the family members of the loved
ones whose lives have been lost
and deserve accurate information data
not the jumping to a conclusion without
having the information okay so that was
yesterday
today that today now same question just
he goes back to
the exact same thing does president
biden think these theories we hear more
about now that coca-19 may have been
man-made and escaped from a lab in china
are a wacky conspiracy theory or based
on what he has heard and been briefed on
does he think that's possible
well we went through this journey
together yesterday so let's do it again
uh
so the president good thing she's
pointing out that he just asked this
yesterday
believes there needs to be an
independent investigation
one that's run by the international
community it's an international pandemic
that has killed hundreds of thousands of
people around the world
he believes the chinese need to do more
to put forward data to be more
transparent and in the second phase of
this
effort he's certainly hopeful that will
be the case and he believes that every
theory should be explored through that
process but that we shouldn't jump to
conclusions before
that data and that information this
entire thing about man-made covid
you know i've never met you the framing
is the left doesn't want to know the
truth
um as as i've been saying
and as so many people have been saying
all along
let's investigate everything about the
origins if the evidence suggested that
covid was man-made
we would want to know that if the
evidence suggests that
it was not man-made but was being
studied at a lab
and then it accidentally leaked out
we would want to know that but absent a
reason to believe that's the case
it's irresponsible to continue pushing
that that's likely or
probable or believed to be true or where
the evidence points
i don't know of anyone saying we should
not investigate
no do not investigate that definitely
don't look into that
nobody's saying that but their obsession
with
all of this stuff that's not based in
fact hydroxychloroquine
uh it's the flu lab leak
dr falchi has money in this and that and
the other thing
uh research it all but the the continued
idea that the left is trying
joe biden refuses to say
it might have been man-made well hold on
just investigate it
and if we have evidence to believe
something then we'll talk about it but
absent that
why is this the narrative and of course
the intent is
to make it seem as though something is
being covered up when when
we have no reason to believe anything's
been covered up sometimes things are
covered up
it's not that cover-ups don't exist it's
not that con conspiracies don't exist
there's no evidence for that at this
point in time um
and by the way yeah i mean as people are
pointing out
the conspiracies that are predicated on
the idea that it was a weapon against
the u.s
it's been mostly non-americans who died
like the official death you know i know
that the real death tolls are much
higher than the
official ones officially 600 000 people
died in the u.s
3.5 million globally a ton of them in
china uh
and in chinese allies so it'd be a very
stupid way
to try to attack the us if that's indeed
what uh
what what china was trying to do all
right huge
thank you to photo fitter for the twitch
sub ramirez arcadia
hi kudos um
thank you all for the twitch prime subs
remember
use the twitch prime sub it doesn't have
to go to me
but don't keep the five bucks with jeff
bezos
if you have amazon prime make sure
you're using your twitch prime sub you
get one free subscription per month
okay i would love to accept it doesn't
have to be me
doesn't have to be me but make sure
you're using it support somebody and
remember it does not automatically renew
also we will open phone lines if we get
to 100 new website members
you can sign up at joinpackman.com we
had someone sign up just moments ago
kennel shaw who i thanked already
and not only will we open phone lines if
we hit the goal today
i will also do an updated garden video
incredible video it will be i promise
you things are exploding you have no
idea what's going on out there and soon
there will be a gardening youtuber who
will be reacting to my garden it's going
to be incredible and then i'll react to
the reaction and it's just
all going to be completely crazy all
right very good do i have any more
voicemails let's take a look
let's see what i've got um
[Music]
uh oh i have 14 new voicemails from
someone
should we do i dare try it do i dare
anytime i see 14 consecutive voicemails
it gets scary
let's start the insanity here we go
my name is michael david moore
oh whoa hold on they're actually they're
about to say where they work
and i don't think uh oh and they're
giving a lot of private info
okay this seems problematic but i'm not
gonna put it on air right now
let's skip that um
i think i've got another one from the
eggman about masks let's see
hey dave help me understand something
what is virtue signaling you say that
republicans
not wearing a mask in senate or congress
is versus signaling
i thought that if you follow the science
and you're vaccinated and you don't need
a mask
like it's like you're told and you still
wear one that's virtue signaling yeah
but the difference is the house still
has rules
and i get it eggman listen i get it
the cdc guidelines and state law
and businesses having a policy
have not always been exactly right but
what i have said from the beginning is
i'm following cdc guidelines when they
don't violate
with the state law and state mandates so
as soon as the cdc said you don't need
masks outside
and states started to say you don't need
masks outside
i took my mask off the house still has a
rule
and so while i agree with the egg man
and we have we interviewed
dr isaac bogash today infectious disease
specialist
and he said that he believes the cdc new
guidelines make sense
you're still violating the rules this
you have to understand the difference
eggman
okay the house has rules let's see what
else he says
maybe we should just get away from this
phrase virtue
signaling and just if you're vaccinated
don't wear a mask and if you're not
wearing a mask at the end
right yeah also remember that like half
or something of
of uh republicans in the house uh have
not gotten vaccinated
that's another crazy thing um and they
they still don't want to wear masks so
it's far more complex than that eggman
all right
um i do have a troy york voicemail he
left four in a row
i know we're not really doing troy york
anymore
let's just listen to one just i'm just
curious what he's even calling about
it's been like a month since
even longer since we heard from him
let's see uh david uh this country
under the leadership of joe biden
we've become a complete laughingstock
untrue i mean we have data uh polling
shows the us is far better regarded now
under biden
the laughing stock was under trump the
polling data proves it
we have no borders we're letting
illegals
into the country to run amok you have
sexual predators yeah these are these
are so boring these talking points being
released
to again repeat their crimes joe biden
is a pathetic human being he's part of
the criminal class
those aren't arguments has become the
democrat party
yeah it's just so boring the i'm sorry
not the eggman
uh yegman's voicemails tend to be
interesting troy york is so desperate to
get on sometimes he'll leave four or
five voicemails in a row
he's out of material he's completely out
of material
and um just who cares you know
who cares quite frankly big thank you to
evan lutt's music
inanis anima lint hole
all of whom just grabbed twitch subs i
appreciate that also thanks to polo doll
who is new member number 14 today okay
let's do something special i am going to
be reviewing
um another one of these classic
interviews
this is an old old old one this is with
a homophobe named brian fisher
he's basically disappeared um
but he is he's disgusting this was a
very early david paquin show interview
let's just dive right into it i think
this was an interesting one all right
here we go
the host of focal point on afr talk
thanks for joining us on short notice
brian
you bet david glad to do it so you've we
in
talking to you via email setting up the
interview we mentioned how we wanted to
talk about how the afa has been
labeled a hate group by the southern
poverty law center
now when i first heard that i said well
first thing is let's figure out
how do you get on that list so we
actually talked to mark potok from
the splc and you know we talked to him
about
how the groups get on there so on and so
forth so we have that piece kind of we
heard his side
so what i would love to hear is tony
perkins has been very vocal
saying the frc he doesn't think belongs
on that list so i would love to hear
your side of how do you react well you
know the interesting thing is david if
you take their criteria and their
criterion for
putting a pro family group on this list
is that they pedal pro-family about
homosexuality
if that is their standard then the
southern poverty law center belongs on
its
own list because they have on their
website what they call 10 myths about
homosexuality
but every single one of them is true so
the reality is it's the southern poverty
law center
that's out there peddling falsehoods
about homosexual behavior so they ought
to be on their own list
so the myths that you mentioned can we
are you okay going through a couple of
them i just figured i'll pick a couple
at random and we'll just see
so let's number one for example
homosexuals molest
children at far higher rates than
heterosexuals you say that that
is that that is actually true this is
absolutely true and this is according to
the journal of sex
research which is not the research arm
of the american family association
it's not not a pro family not a
conservative organization the journal of
sex
research indicates that homosexual
pedophiles are responsible for
33 percent roughly of all child
sex offenses so to be clear we're the
ones that are telling the truth about
the link between homosexuality
southern poverty law center is peddling
falsehoods they belong on their own list
so this is just to be clear you're
referring to the 89 journal of sex
research article by kurt
frond is that oh i believe that's the
one yes i don't have that information
right in front of me so here's the thing
i looked this up because i
in you know i tried to do as much due
diligence as possible and i looked this
up and what it what it seems to say
is that uh that this is actually the
opposite of what kurt
runs study indicated so in other words
you're saying
33 assuming every case of men molesting
boys is committed by a homosexual my
opinion and you tell me where i'm wrong
is that pedophilia is not an issue of
gay or straight it is somebody who is
attracted to to youth is it not
uh no you can be attracted to youth of
the same sex or youth of the opposite
sex if you are attracted to youth of the
same sex
that is homosexual attraction that not
according to
to those who study this in mental health
they say that it is an issue of
the prepubescent nature of someone and
it has nothing to do with with gay or
straight
well that's just simply ridiculous david
i mean
how do you think homosexuality by
definition is being attracted
to somebody of the same sex yes but that
is once you are passed be you once you
are not prepubescent
though it doesn't make sense to me to
think that it is pr if you're attracted
to someone who is prepubescent
as an adult that seems to be a sickness
that is not an issue of being gay or
straight i don't know
sure i mean if an adult male is
attracted to a young girl
a member of the opposite sex by the way
this guy on his land line is classic
right
sickness if an adult male is attracted
to a member of the same sex
that too is a mental disorder it's a
sickness but it is an attraction to
somebody of
the same sex i mean it's ridiculous to
try to say that that's not what's going
on here i mean the plain obvious facts
are
here is an adult who is attracted to
somebody of the same sex
that by definition is homosexuality okay
well i think i think we're going to have
to agree to disagree on that one um
let's let's look at uh i don't know
maybe myth number four homosexuals don't
live as long
you say that that is true absolutely and
this is according
once again to a secular source the
international journal of epidemiology
they did a longitudinal study of the
active homosexual community in vancouver
british columbia
they came to the conclusion that active
participation in the homosexual
lifestyle
will deprive a male of anywhere between
8 and 20 years of his life expectancy
and then just last year the canadian
reigns what is this guy talking about
beau health coalition this is a
homosexual activist group
in canada they listed they produced a
list of health issues affecting
queer canadians that's their term not my
queer canadians
and the first thing they mention is
lower life expectancy
so even homosexual activist groups david
are
admitting this is just last year that
participation homosexual
lifestyle will the lifestyle reduce your
longevity now brian you know that a lot
of the people who studies you're quoting
are personally angry with you for
for for what they are saying is is
misrepresenting their data right i mean
stephanie strafty
who's associate hold on a second brian
let me just get the question out
stephanie strathe who's associate dean
of global health sciences at
uc san diego and she actually authored
one of the one of the reports that you
you state is here's a quote i am aghast
that the misrepresentation of these data
continues and her argument is and this
is her argument
is that new studies actually point out
that the significant advances in hiv and
aids treatment
have significantly significantly
improved the life expectancies of those
who are infected
and that the landscape has changed
significantly well that's fine
significantly improved does not mean
it's the same or better i mean well it
makes his eight to 20 years number
ridiculous doesn't it
she's admitting that there is an impact
on longevity maybe that gap is shrinking
but
she's even admitting that it's still
there you claim that gay people can
choose to leave homosexuality and you
base that on the fact that some people
claim to have left is that right
absolutely i mean i've met them when i
pastored i had them speak in my church
okay so that proves that it's not the
hell of a church by the way
it's possible can you understand though
how it would be possible for someone to
claim they have left while that is not
really the reality can you imagine that
type of circumstance
you can and you can can you understand
why people might have that
motivation to do that based on either
being ostracized in their communities
or for a number of other reasons just
because you have met someone who claims
to have left
does that mean that people can really
stop being homosexual
well sure i mean i i've met people that
have i mean that is living
they've pastored at his church he said
it proof i mean it's right there
in front of your very eyes is that to
say that everybody that tries to leave
the lifestyle is successful of course
not
but it is obviously possible to change
reorient yourself sexually people are
doing it every day
so from this i gather that logically you
must believe that people choose to
either be gay or be straight at some
point right i mean
it's a choice sexual behavior is a
choice
now i may not be able to do anything
about the kind of sexual temptations
that i experience
i'm choosing to yield to those sexual
temptations that is
always a choice i mean you can ask tiger
woods
uh what happens when you yield to every
sexual temptation that comes your way
so hold on a second so when you said
that people can stop
being gay you're actually saying they
can just
stop committing sexual acts with people
of the same sex they can't actually stop
being gay right
well i'm saying that every sexual act is
a matter of choice
okay but but do you see what i'm getting
at here because when you talk about
you've met people that used to be gay
you're not actually indicating really
that they stopped being gay they are
just no longer
having sex with others of the same
gender right they're two very different
things i don't think he gets it well no
the people that i've talked to again and
this is based on my own personal
experience and from
studies i've read from organizations
that help people leave the lifestyle
studies he's read from organizations
that help people
leave the gay lifestyle their actual
orientation does
change they develop a sexual attraction
toward members
of the opposite sex some of the men that
i had speak in my church were not
happily married and
and the father of children but so i i'm
just i'm getting so confused here and
maybe i'm just misunderstanding it
you're claiming that people can choose
the sexual acts they engage in but they
cannot choose who they are attracted to
that is that is something you're born
with but again you just said
the people you know have changed who
they are attracted to i'm just
i'm not saying people are born that way
i'm just now you're not saying
no i'm destroying a distinction but what
is the distinction i don't even get it
between
sexual temptation and sexual behavior
because i may not be able to control the
kind of sexual temptations
that i experience but i can decide which
of those
impulses i yield to maybe i'm just not
going to understand it because i'm
hearing you saying
people can't control the sexual
temptations that they have they can
control their actions
but the people you know that are now
happily straight were able to control
the temptations they're no longer
tempted to be gay is that
am i hearing something wrong no no
transformation is possible
yes okay i it's obviously happened i
mean it can't happen
you know even uh robert spitzer he was
the psychologist that engineered the the
politically motivated
declassification of homosexuality as a
mental disorder in 1973.
he admitted several years ago he did an
extensive why is a guy like this so
obsessed with homosexuality
i still you know when i was doing these
interviews i didn't really get it
now i really don't get it like why why
why does he care about this study of
groups that work with people trying to
change their sexual orientation
and he came to the conclusion that it is
possible this is robert spitzer columbia
university
doesn't work for frc doesn't work for
afa
probably shares most of the goals of the
homosexual agenda
yet he himself has said after looking at
this issue himself the change is
possible
yeah but you know what he actually after
after saying that he actually said you
know
it's possible if you're highly motivated
to to uh
switch sexual activity but cases of
actual conversion from gay to straight
work
this is his quote probably extremely
rare
and he also has recorded an online
appeal asking anti-gay organizations
like yours
to stop misrepresenting i was pretty
well prepared for this i have to tell
you
this is this is spitzer specifically
another instance but hold on brian
you have a track record of getting
people who do research on these issues
saying i need brian fisher to stop
misrepresenting my research
no i'm not butchering their research i'm
quoting them verbatim david how can you
distort somebody or misrepresent
somebody
when you are quoting them verbatim
quotes
you're not changing their words you're
not twisting their words you are
quoting them that's not
misrepresentation that's quotation
you know we're going to have a certain
percentage of people that that will
claim to do anything
but you're making it seem like it's just
a run-of-the-mill thing you know people
that are ex-gay now they're happily
straight
but spitzer is saying my research did
not indicate that that is common
my research does not indicate that that
is reasonable it is probably extremely
rare
but see david realized he is admitting
that it's possible
he says it's rare he is agreeing with me
that change is possible
let's play that out to its logical
conclusion and that will get into an
inter like mid-roll membership frame
here next topic which is
let's say we all agree it's a choice and
people can just change it if they want
to stop being gay they can stop being
gay
let's just for a second say i agree with
you and that all the evidence suggests
you're right
bear with me here if it is a lifestyle
choice since
when do we discriminate against people
based on lifestyle choices i mean if
you're a punk rocker or a vegetarian etc
if it is a lifestyle choice why would we
allow
discrimination against that lifestyle
choice in terms of marriage in terms of
you know don't ask don't tell
explain it to me well again we're
talking here about behavior think david
for a minute about the billions and
billions of dollars that we spend
trying to convince our kids not to take
up smoking
but that's a silly that's that's a silly
argument because you know there's
evidence that
pilots are regularly exposed to higher
levels of radiation
because they're spending time up in
airplanes where the ozone is thinner
should we is is that a lifestyle choice
that should also be discriminated
against i mean come on brian
well no let's go back to the smoking
analogy i mean it's clearly a lifestyle
choice people can quit they can do it it
may not be easy
some people may try and they may lapse
back but we spend billions of dollars
telling people because of the health
risks involved in developing a smoking
habit
don't start if you started stop and my
suggestion is we spend the
same amount of money convincing our
young
young people not to start experimenting
with homosexuality
and if you're engaged in that lifestyle
it's time to stop
and we'll do what we can to help you
well okay so i'm not
very familiar with gay sex myself being
heterosexual i know that you speak and
write about it a lot so i just want to
ask you
[Laughter]
oh man oh man
these were the days huh what about a
monogamous gay relationship
is risky or causes hiv that we should be
telling people
no absolutely don't do that if that
that's that's a lifestyle you don't want
what is risky about a monogamous gay
relationship
well the problem david is that there is
no such thing as a monogamous homosexual
relationship
you look at the research and homosexuals
themselves
will will admit many of them have as
many as 500 to a
thousand sexual partners over the course
of a lifetime
if you've ever if you've ever watched if
you've ever watched the howard stern
show you know there's plenty of women
with those
with those records with men as well well
i mean that's a pretty
significant record and i would say to a
woman if you're having 500 to a thousand
sexual partners in your life
you have got to stop you are doing
enormous you're exposing your
your health to enormous risk please for
god's sake and for your own sake
stop it so it sounds like you would say
to anyone regardless of gender
orientation if they're having sex with
500 people that's not good but the
question remains
in a monogamous gay relationship what is
the risk
there is no such thing but that's just
completely bogus how could anybody
possibly believe that sexuals themselves
will tell you that
you know when i had these guys came to
my church and speak they said you know
i was in one of these churches
relationships
these are the ex-gay guys right yeah
ex-gay guys we had an agreement me and
my partner we had an agreement
that we could fool around on the side we
would live together maybe we would be
each other's primary sexual outlet
right we had an understanding that we
could fool around on the side and he
said that is common in the homosexual
community
hey i know that we're we're getting
anecdotal here i mean it
get it sounds like there is no risk to a
monogamous gay relationship right
oh sure there is any time you do you
engage in anal sex
but that is dangerous to human health
the uh
rectal wall is one cell thick
one cell what could that mean what does
that mean one cell
it's a weird comment right it's easily
torn
so it allows any kind of disease
infection
ready access to the bloodstream it's a
bad idea
it's a bad idea whether you're straight
or gay okay so
again you would tell women or men who
have sex with a lot of men not to do
that
you would tell women or men not to have
anal sex so again it sounds like this
these are just general sex tips from
brian fisher not even directed at
homosexuality
exactly right okay
[Laughter]
gay sex and domestic terrorism with
great interest we heard you make the
comparison of
recently on your radio program the
logical conclusion is that those
engaging in gay sex
should be jailed agree or disagree i i
never said
i've never said anything david about
jailing homosexuals but i'm asking you
one single time not ever it's my ques no
i'm i'm saying it i'm not misquoting you
my question is
is that something that would be the
logical conclusion if gay sex is
terrorism would it not make sense to
jail those people we ought to take our
cue
from gay porn actors gay porn acts what
the hell is going on doctors are out
there now saying look
it is dangerous to have sex on a set
without a condom
we need to have requirements that that
gay actors who perform
in gay porn we need to have a
requirement that they wear condoms
so i'm showing far more confidence in
following the lead of gay porn actors
than homosexual activists are because
i'm saying we ought to follow their lead
no and the gay porn actors i know
are thrilled to have your support but my
question is should it be a felony
i am saying david that we ought to
impose the same sanctions
that gay porn actors say we ought to
impose something's really really wrong
with this guy
really wrong but i'm with them i'm with
them on this you're with the gay porn
actors
yes but you've got to realize david it
was a felony offense
in the united states of america in every
state in the union until 1962. well it
used to be
a felony in 49 states until 1972
right and it was still a felony in 12
states in 2003 when the lawrence v texas
ruling came down
well yeah and it used to be legal to own
slaves and blacks weren't allowed in the
military we know we can cite old law
can't we
well you're comparing apples and oranges
there let's talk about
both of which are fruit by the way the
theories that many have about
latent homosexuality among anti-gay
activists
oh this is where i think i start asking
him why he's so obsessed with this this
i think this is a good part is that a
legitimate concern i mean i get a lot of
emails
we interviewed paul cameron we
interviewed peter la barbara in advance
of my interview with you
there are many people that say you know
somebody who is so visibly active
in trying to prevent homosexuality and
and influence what people are doing in
the privacy of their own home
they must be themselves gay i mean can
you refute that
even refutiated if you want like sarah
palin does what do you think of that
absolutely you know my point on david
would be those homosexual activists that
are so
intent on normalizing homosexual
behavior
they are so intent on silencing and
punishing heterosexuals
they must be harboring some deep
seated longing to be straight they must
really be underneath all of that anger
all of that aggression
they must secretly be heterosexual
that's my response the accusation is
that the anti-gay activists are the ones
who are really latently homosexual
and and and i'm i'm saying that if that
our
argument stands yeah then homosexual
activists must be latently heterosexual
uh so let's just wrap up here you know
that you guys are going to lose on this
right i mean it is obvious don't
ask don't tell will be repealed gay
marriage is now by the way who was right
on these predictions who was for listen
to these predictions illegal
in more states than it ever has been and
it's certainly not going to be a number
that decreases
my question is what's next my producer
thought it would be abortion and stem
cell research for the for the so-called
pro-family groups
what is going to be the next step well
you know i really don't know that kind
of depends on the cultural and state
escape and the way it shifts you know we
don't believe that the battle over don't
ask don't tell is over
by any means it may not look promising
at this point but we don't believe that
that battle is over
you know when the american people david
have been able to go to the polls and
vote on the definition of marriage we
are 31 and oh 31
states have amended their state
constitutions to define marriage
as the union of one man and one woman
yeah but again brian that's
it's complete other states have laws
against it it's completely worthless to
cite that because as we know we can't
just put
anything to a vote what if we want to
put the right to bear arms to a vote i
mean nobody would back that up
if we just ask people's opinion we're
not going to get anywhere you know that
well that's not people's opinion david
that's what they did at the ballot box
i understand but what i'm saying is if
we just go by everything that is put to
a
to a vote uh we would still not have
blacks in the military right i mean when
we surveyed the military in the 40s
70 to 80 said nope no blacks in the
military so
the idea that because people voted for
it is going to be law i would put a
challenge i would or that it's right
even say this
i would like you to join us again one
year from today and tell us tell me now
will there be more or less states in a
year should have said more or fewer
that's my mistake where gay marriages
are legal
well i do not think you're going to see
any one of those 31 states that have it
in their state constitutions i don't see
any way
that they're going to disamend or
unamend their boy
this guy must be in shambles at this
point that is real that is interesting
it's interesting to see i believe that
this interview was originally
from where was the this might have been
originally from 2011. i know we reposted
it in 2014. i think it must have been
2011.
um pretty stunning actually
at just how wrong all of these people
were
right i mean really really something
else um
i wonder if he's even like what is he
doing now let's see brian
fisher focal point with brian fisher
uh two hours ago wow he did a show today
let's
see what he's doing today
[Music]
got judgment for a period of time and
those are the kind of
political leaders we want and we're
going to see by the way
100 views 100 views guys
okay let's get let's see what he's up to
about how to identify him
in this passage today we're in second
kings chapter 18
through chapter 19 verse 7. you can go
to parade so is he just doing like bible
study now because
they lost on gay marriage.afa.net you
can read with us and you can pray with
us
all the way through the word of god
start today three years from today you
will have prayed through
and read through the entire word of god
in consumable
chunks bite-sized chunks you know you
get those one year through the bible
programs
you get behind a day or two man there's
no way you're catching up
but with this schedule over three years
how much does that cost
easily get caught up if you happen to
miss a day and the prayers are crafted
from the very words
of scripture all right well let's uh
look at second kings chapter 18.
okay i mean i don't want him to do bible
study but let's just see what else he
does during this thing
or involvement whatsoever now why was he
doing that
well realize he's got a lot of risk here
because he stands to lose everything
if the truth about his involvement in
this the fact that he paid
for the coronavirus with u.s taxpayer
dollars he would be finished
they bought the corona who bought the
coronavirus
so he's got to cover his tracks and this
is back when it just began
he said i'm going to lay this line down
i'm going to hope everybody buys it
nobody will poke into this
where this thing comes you look at
evolutionary scientists everybody knows
that this thing totally originated in
nature well
without any help without any
bioengineering so again he's just trying
to pull his own fat
so i guess it's like christianity and
conspiracism or something like that
how crazy is this so that's
that's what brian fisher is now up to
unbelievable
uh i do want to say thank you to
um james filerman
who just signed up at joinpackman.com i
appreciate that james
also a big thank you to maulberry
ranch fiend billy in 4c
do you grok mk aviators
victorious ms unlikely gamer
all of whom just signed up via twitch
which i very very much
appreciate all right that's all i had
planned for today i appreciate everybody
joining me
we will have a big public biden event
coming up tomorrow and many many more
things coming up
leading up to what i guess memorial day
the memorial day holiday okay thanks
everybody for joining me if you have
stuff you want me to go over on
tomorrow's stream
info davidpakman.com and i will see
everybody
tomorrow